this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
what's up guys michael here to talk
about how
a simple golden ring can change a man's
life forever
wow
[Music]
i'm not talking about marriage i'm
talking about the lord of the rings and
today in particular
we're going to take a philosophical
gander at our friends in the shire but
before we get into it i want to tell you
about this video's sponsor keeps did you
know that two out of three men will
experience male pattern baldness in some
form
by the time they're 35. keeps is here to
help by making it easier and more
affordable to prevent hair loss with
their convenient subscription service
first you get a free consultation with a
licensed keeps doctor who will choose
which combination of fda approved
prescriptions and over-the-counter
medications are right for you now
throughout the process you'll be able to
message your keeps doctor 24 7 to let
them know how your treatment is going
and every three months your medication
refills will automatically land on your
doorstep when it comes to hair loss
prevention is key the treatments can
typically take four to six months to
start seeing results so get started
today if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
wisecrack or click the link in the
description to receive 50 off your first
order that's keps.com
wisecrack now back to the show okay i'm
sure you've all seen this movie a lot of
times so i'm gonna start right at the
beginning with something that i think
sets things up well
not a lot of movies where you see
someone kind of defeat the bad guy
but the hearts of men
are easily corrupted okay so i like what
is said there that the hearts of men are
easily corrupted and the ring of power
has a will of its own now i think the
idea here is that a ring such as the
ring in the film can reveal the true
nature or character of a person and this
is a huge idea that's explored in
plato's republic in particular book two
of the republic where socrates is
talking to a couple of dudes about the
nature of justice now the guy socrates
is talking to who are plato's brothers
bring up the myth of the ring of gaijins
and this ring is similar to the ring we
get in the movie right the idea is that
you get it you can go invisible and you
can do whatever you want now in the
republic these two argue that the ring
is proof that no one really has a desire
for justice because in the myth this guy
gets the ring was a decent farmer but he
puts it on and he kills the king and he
sleeps with his wife and becomes a
really bad dude
let's jump ahead to see what happens
when gandalf tries to get help from his
old mentor saruman
it's crazy to me that anyone ever
thought sauerman was like a good guy
he's clearly a very bad guy you could
just see it when you look at
him also it's funny that gandalf thinks
here
that he's not gonna close one of the
doors
the hill finally can't close it's like
come on dude you did not seriously think
that a hobbit could contend with the
will of sauron
there are none who can
gandalf's reaction is like when you
realize
we must join that like your grandparent
who you love is actually kind of a
racist and you're like oh no be my
friend
when did sarah and the wise abandon
reason for madness and here there's a
distinction between reason and madness
and i think madness we can think of as a
type of unreason which is more a passion
or appetite that's driving human
behavior okay so in the republic plato
maps out a tripartite account of the
soul just means three parts and the
three parts are reason spirit and
appetite so reason also called um logic
or lagos
represents a philosophical ruler in the
republic and this person values justice
and virtue of of all else it's the
justice focused rational faculty now
justice occurs when spirit works in
accordance with reason and not in the
service of appetite now injustice occurs
when spirit is in service of appetite
when it's pure desire driving what the
individual does now here gandalf is
saying to sariman that he's abandoned
the faculty of reason or logic and
instead is letting that desire for power
that spirit that's focused on appetite
drive what he's doing now in the
republic plato describes reason as being
the smallest part of these three
elements but it's the most important
because it unifies everything else and
drives it towards justice because
without reason without logic without
that desire towards justice people would
just do whatever they want for the sake
of their own desire i think we can see
that throughout this movie that sort of
distinction between are people driven by
the part of their soul that desires
justice and reason or by the part of
their soul that wants honor and fame or
by the part of their soul that just
wants raw power and to feel good and do
whatever they want oh it's the first
time we see our fellowship
they must decide now how to end it the
time of the elves is over my people are
leaving me
who will you look to when we've gone
it is in men that we must bless our hope
it's really weird that gandalf believes
in men so much but good good for us
the race of men is failing the blood of
new menorah is all but spent it's pride
and difficult hates us though el rendez
because of men the ring survives
i was there gandalf i was there the day
the strength of men failed
okay so here elrond says that the
strength of men failed when isilda did
not destroy the ring which would benefit
all of middle earth and instead kept it
for himself to give himself power so
back to plato's account of the soul
this would be an example of logic being
superseded by desire if silver's
appetite for power was stronger than his
desire for justice and elrond thinks
this indicates a weakness in the souls
of humans overall but for plato it would
be that a soldier hadn't really
cultivated a love of justice and reason
right he would say that he lacks a
properly philosophical spirit and
because of this he would not be a good
leader now this comes up in the republic
where socrates brings out this paradox
of who would be an ideal ruler an ideal
king as the type of person who actively
wants to rule wants to be a king
socrates says is the opposite of the
person who should rule and then the
person who should rule is often someone
who would not want to do that so plato's
ideal ruler is a philosopher because he
would be focused wholly on justice and
nothing else he has chosen exile
okay so obviously they're talking about
aragorn when elrond says he's chosen
exile this is interesting and i think it
applies to what i just talked about
with the account of philosopher kings in
the republic and how people that want to
be leaders should not be leaders people
who don't want to be leaders are often
the best suited and here we're seeing
aragorn as someone who has actively
turned his back
on royalty on leadership because he's
cultivated a sense of justice and virtue
over and against a desire for his own
power gondor has no key
condor needs no king i can't help here
but think of plato's republic where the
role of the king the philosopher king in
the republic
is that sense of reason and logic and i
think when he says that gondor and by
proxy obviously bormir himself you know
needs no king it makes sense because
he's saying it might not have that sense
of reason and justice and is driven by
desire and that's basically what we see
when boromir is arguing that he should
have the ring to protect his people
we got ourselves a golem that's
something frodo doesn't know that
they're about to become great friends
he's been following us for three days
many that live deserve death
some that die deserve life
can you give it to them
i think this is interesting because
what's going on here is that gandalf is
acknowledging that the goodness of one's
soul isn't some inherent fact right the
desire for justice orients one soul in a
way that makes you a more just and kind
and happy and virtuous person orienting
oneself towards desire and injustice
corrupts and destroys your soul and
that's what happened with smeagle on his
way to becoming golem being oriented
towards straight-up desire leads him
away from justice makes him just a
miserable little beard and of course we
all know this scene he's just like take
the ring i don't want it i don't want
this responsibility
and she just goes sicko mode just total
sicko mode
it's very scary
looks evil as hell
but
we got here and
[Music]
i passed the test
why did she say that she's past the test
well right here she had this moment
where she was tempted by the power of
the ring
but because her character because her
principles were virtuous she was able to
not give in even though by not accepting
the ring it basically means that
the elves have to leave middle earth she
knows that that's going to affect her
negatively
but she refuses to let the ring corrupt
her soul
in this scene when she says you're a
ring bearer it makes me think there's a
famous episode of the show
how i met your mother where the
character barney says he's gotten a ring
bearer and his friends all say did you
say bearer big bear because they're
worried he's gonna bring a bear to a
wedding and i think we can put the clip
in if i'm right here we really do have a
ring bear what
okay jumping ahead a bit they will fine
and we all know this is a scene we all
knew was coming
where boromir just couldn't
couldn't hang on anymore
give it to me
dang invisible mode and no two the frodo
does use the ring but he uses it to get
out of harry situations okay so after
just almost getting robbed and murdered
by boromir um frodo runs up to aragorn
i would have gone with you to the end
this is important because again he's
tempted directly with the power of the
ring but he shows that he is virtuous of
character his soul is being driven by
reason and logic which is oriented
towards justice so he's able to do the
right thing and it's not even that hard
for him compare that to boromir who is
someone whose
soul is more driven by his appetites and
his desires for power not driven by a
rational faculty that's focused on
justice it's almost like aragorn and
plato's terms would make a good
king
we'll see okay so unless you thought i
was going to end this video without
getting to boromir's final moments
we get a little bit of redemption
again showing
it's just a real mess
it's not that in his falling to the
temptation of the ring that it means his
soul is just outright bad he's screwed
up but we see him dying with a sense of
honor because he recognizes that
temptation towards injustice he
recognizes that his soul was oriented
towards desire and power more than it
was justice which gets back to that
point once again that would be plato's
point that injustice can corrupt the
soul justice can sort of inform and
enliven and enrich the soul it's not
just that you make
one bad decision and you're screwed
forever although he is dead forever
that's you know he's he's a human
and he's dead so he's dead now but he
went down like a g so what are you gonna
say okay so there you have it by
watching a great movie the fellowship of
the ring we can learn a lot about the
nature of the soul and the nature of
justice in plato specifically i was
talking a lot about stuff that's in book
two of the republic so
read plato's republic if you haven't
already and as always thank you so much
for watching and thanks to our patrons
for all that you do to support us do
check out our patreon page if you
haven't in a while we have a lot of cool
new features there including a lot of
extra philosophical resources as this is
your sort of thing also check out our
new stream wisecrack live it happens
right here every thursday at 11am
pacific please like this video if you
enjoyed it subscribe ring that bell all
those sorts of things and as always
thank you so much for watching later
[Music]
you